two we're back it's families you know
what it is
i got my mom i got my dad hello
where this is episode number four people
like the show apparently
thank goodness what do you think about
being liked by people on the internet
that you don't know
well i think everybody is just so nice
my girlfriend and i were walking uh in
one of the malls
here locally and a young man
from behind said excuse me
and i turned around he goes you're donna
and i said yeah i am and he just told me
how much he enjoyed the show and was
looking forward to
to today wow and um damn you came down
hard on that desk with your ring do that
again
well you guys both do that they both
have big-ass rings and they have this
thing where they have to slam the ring i
didn't mean to
she's just trying to get all the pink
off the table yeah let's get this
sand this sucker down so today's episode
is sponsored by curology
quip me undies and honey and you'll be
happy to know that sponsors like you too
because there's
a ton of them lately really yeah they
look great they like donna specifically
they come for donna they stay for i was
gonna say gary but let's be honest
yeah let's be honest and ethan yeah yeah
definitely
okay well but love it's for me it's
you gotta make it oh come on people like
your wit
what's the criticism you're getting
online
uh most of it comes from
uh my son revealing my
the people i follow on twitter oh can i
can i tell gusting person i am well
hold on i resent that i mean the man
consumes pornography who does not
guess what your father got in the middle
i mean yes you do yes
no oh
hold on hold on hold on oops just
because you watch blowbang
hub on twitter
doesn't mean yeah okay so my mom said
guess what dad got
and he gave her one of these so now
let's reveal it and if it's too hot to
handle we can cut it out how's that for
a
agreement can i guess
pill no no no how dare you i don't know
okay so what could it be now you better
tell me right now i guess
dad got a uh someone reaching out to him
from the pornography industry
and asked was a company hold on it was
okay it was a company
and they wanted to know if dad was
interested in this particular
care package so oh my god
they thanked me for dude wait how did
they get your address
they dm me and you provided your address
i just said somewhere in the valley and
they mailed it and it dude
that but okay so you're getting a little
crazy but you become like an ambassador
of the adult entertainment industry
you're getting your dad's
name no you told me that some girl
offered you free only fans
that's correct
[Laughter]
but i i dare not so i do they
you can pay for it now with the success
of this show
i don't have to pay and i still turned
it down
they got they sent dad like shirts
and it was a box of mine it was sweat
should we shout it out i know they're
probably looking for exposures they're
gonna have to pay me
and and team skeet shout out
you asked you asked that is like a
really nasty one
what it isn't team ski like they're just
a regular
wait hold on you know what skeeting is
what
am i correct in assuming that skeeting
is like the act of a man finishing
i think so so you're on team skeet
you're officially on team skeet
well i'm an unpaid spokesman maybe
there's no pay it was very nice of them
oh yeah and very nice inside the box
they had i almost brought it to you but
then i gave it to jessica because
she's got a little dog too dobby and i
didn't think you'd let shredder wear it
the team's eat yeah it had a it had a
hood
and it was for a dog and jessica's
jessica's not going to put that on her
dog
it doesn't fit yeah there's nothing
promiscuous
or yeah but it's fully related except
for some stickers they put in well
well other than the fact that it says
team skeet on it exactly
which is the act of a man finishing
i'm not aware of that uh familiar with
that expression right
uh well i'm telling you you say so all
right well
my dad has joined team skeet so that's a
big development congratulations sorry
babe
it would be a little too much to say
i've joined i know you'll graduate once
you start getting blocked
uh merge that's when we'll know that
you've really uh ascended
what kind of merge blocked i'm not sure
i know i haven't heard from them yet but
email address is no uh google it when
you're reach me through the show mom
if you're curious
okay don't i mean do or do if you're
anybody like take a guess what do you
think black is
i don't have a clue just take a guess
you know what it is she's so naive you
know something about duties
oh mom i don't know
brown oh i don't know what's black
i don't think that's even legal in the
united states to have like scat
scat adult entertainment like you can't
find that anywhere and i've looked
hey shredder all right well so you can
go home and google black
later on okay do you know what it is
no in passing
i don't know well anyway mom if people
like you today they're not going to like
you after this show because we are doing
controversial taste
and i'm pretty sure you two are getting
cancelled
[Laughter]
um so we're doing controversial takes um
and also you guys have prepared a
tick-tock dance
that's exciting we've actually practiced
and not sure is that why you're dressed
like a mormon today dad
yeah we're in yeah i just forgot my
elder gary
elder gary gary the wizard are there
wizards and has something to do with it
yeah oh there's no way costume so to
speak
in our 70s and then uh
well if we got more advice it's gonna be
a really fun episode but before we get
started first thing i want to do is
introduce you to more slang
oh and i want to give you another bonus
opportunity
where if you were using this word
correctly at any time during the show
you get an extra one hundred dollars
wow pay attention this time i forgot
dad was not happy with your performance
the last time a bonus was offered
so here on god
yeah you remember ching ching hundred
dollars
all right here we go okay hot girl
summer what is a hot girl summer mom
a hot girl summer
hot girl summer
something about a bathing suit okay
hot girl summer let's say you know what
this summer
now that kovit's gone i'm definitely
having a hot girl summer
hanging out with the girls laying out by
the pool
no it's a girl having a carefree single
sexy summer okay i'm fully vaccinated
and it's time for a hot girl
summer okay that makes sense yeah that
makes sense
okay here's a good one for you bet
bet like b-e-t bet
well i mean we all know what the word
bet means
bet i'll bet you can't do this
or that's very literal uh guess dad do
you have a guess on bet
second letter of the hebrew alphabet
that is also true but not what i'm
looking for
okay bet i'll be there at 10 a.m
but oh i'll be there at 10 00 a.m
changing 10 a.m it's just oh well then
how did you define it
well why why ten oh anytime you want
i'll be there at
nine okay okay bet i'll be so defined
so defined bet whatever time you're
gonna be there you're telling someone
you're gonna be
or you can bet on it exactly
dad they got it affirmed okay it's a
little slow you can bet on it no it's
hard don't play it don't feel bad
100 for me no we haven't gotten to the
bonus part so you can you can take it to
the bank
you can bet on it okay a shorty or
shouty shorty or
shouty shouty god
let me think that that
shorty or a shouty [ __ ] i was a little
bit taller i wish it was a baller
dad would be your shouty is that right
then that my dad would be my mom's
shorty or is it only a female
well it's usually a female but like
better it doesn't really matter
you you you would be dad's shouty
is that with an r or with a oh you jake
it's shorty but it's pronounced shouty
his
partner it would be your
female significant other okay so ela
would be my
shorty shorty or
okay well that's easy my shorty
slaps those are the things you wear on
your feet
in the summer no i mean true well slaps
is it i don't know sandals
yeah you know the flip-flops flip-flop i
never heard about a slap
yeah because they've slapped your feet
when you when you wear them
right don't they maybe that's true well
i've made up a word
okay slap but that's not what i'm
looking for slaps this domino's pizza
slaps really that's the word
wow it slaps me nauseous tasty
this it it's good it's tasty
slaps mom is correct it's slaps this is
very good this pizza slaps
wow okay there's a lot of words okay
i'm gonna have to go over this shooketh
it sounds biblical right
have you seen the new teddy fresh
collection i am shooketh
happy um no
it means shaken or amazed
you are welcome you are kind of happy
from amazement
i am shook okay okay now here's the one
that's your
this is the one that you're gonna get a
bonus on okay what
it's eat eat
eat guess what yeet
means oh lord
give me a hint i
let's see uh shredder bit
shredder bit theodore so i yieded him
punished not quite punished
yelled at scolded let me see
um
no no i was playing uh
uh i was playing baseball and i heated
the ball
out of the park
slam it means to propel an object
through the air
at alarming speeds jettison
[Music]
who's making these up this is a very
popular word
slang i hate to sound like a boomer but
slang was much cooler
when when we were young well it may i
yeah i don't know
really give me one example groovy
oh that's horrible how about bitching
that was a good one
people say bitching do they still i mean
it's still in parliament yeah still
comes
cool everyone still uses cool has never
really left i mean
you can't you can't claim cool
you really
okay you don't you guys don't like eat
well it turns out that yeet
is going to be your bonus 100 word today
so anytime you can use yeet in a correct
sentence correct
correctly pronounced you'll get a
hundred dollars
okay do you want to try to use wheat
before eat wheat
did you try to eat before we continue
could you define the word again please
something out of the ballpark to propel
an object through the air at alarming
speed okay ready
so okay let me go over the words again
just you the only one you need to
remember
oh okay all right that makes it a little
easier you want to try to use it in a
sentence
uh her podcast was
yeet all right i'm not paying out any
money
well how does that mean accessible she
hit it out of the park with her podcast
i mean it's ye you're using it like a
noun or something
i mean right yes podcast is so i have to
use it like
uh a verb
a verb listen you do
all i know is that something eating is
something you do to an object does that
help you
okay all right so it's not figurative
it's literal
it's very literal it doesn't get more
literal than a year okay
all right let's move on i know when you
graduate from from your class you
eat your your hat that's true in the air
does that okay but that does that count
you mean you're just defining the word
yeah i'm defining yeah
yes that's the correct usage of you okay
okay first thing at the top of the show
dad this one's for you
there's been a lot of people in the
community saying that you look
identical too guess who do you think you
look like
stephen king you don't like that at that
comparison
it is pretty uncanny you have to admit
you're much better looking
no offense you've been you find that to
be an insult on your physical appearance
uh not if we were just going
intellectually
right yeah you're physically i don't
know he's he
he's a little thinner than i am i have
more hair
now he's got a lot of hair colonel
sanders a mix of colonel sanders and
stephen king
which do you prefer well they started to
shoot
colonel sanders uh kentucky fried
chicken commercials with
george hamilton and some other
references that no one watching this
show will get but
you know actors that were uh
uh not quite as old-looking mm-hmm
i don't think stephen that's not who
they're called that's not who they're
comparing you to well there wasn't a lot
of kernels
well come take a look at this i got a
photo on the uh
i think you're look at that even a young
looking stephen no
dad's better looking listen i'm not
passing a value judgment on stephen
king's looks i'm just saying
he looks more like he came with his
beard i mean look at that that's like
doppelganger [ __ ] dude
and you also probably did as much
cocaine as stephen king as well
that part's probably true right i don't
know
he has a lot more money than me so uh
but he's got that like with without the
mustache
i have a really big flip i think and he
has the same thing which yeah
you grow a mustache so you can't see the
gigantic
man if you whatever you call that thing
no it's true you do have a big upper lip
and i don't know if it's just because
i'm used to
not seeing you with facial hair but you
have that same
you've got i mean that's you i'm sorry
to tell you you're stephen king he needs
to grow his mustache back
all right there you have that okay so we
did this segment on the podcast
where we all shared an embarrassing
story
right and a controversial slash
unpopular
opinion so i'm figuring you guys have
had these long fulfilling lives
you got to have some good stories so who
so mom you want to go first with an
embarrassing story
how about if you let dad go for her you
go first
yeah you go first you want dad to go
first
all right i'll go first go ahead it's
really it's horrendous
really it's horrifying i mean
i asked dad if i should tell it and he
said well it's a good one
but oh my god i can't believe i'm
actually sure it is for people
i love it thank you okay so it's kind of
along
the vein of your discovery
of the dildo wow where is this going
oh my god so i don't know what it is
with you guys
that you're always getting into our
stuff that's
obvious of course the kids get into this
stuff i never you have to assume
not the good child sorry to interrupt
you
please bro my brother was the one
leading the way are you crazy oh god
by the way when you are gone all the
time yeah and you have young boys at
home
and probably i'm not a girl so i'm
assuming girls do this too they're
looking through everything no but you
guys were looking for
money okay and jessica
say this childhood criminal jessica
was looking for money but you said i was
looking for money
no no no didn't you jessica oh she was
looking for money
ethan's sister we were looking for porn
jessica was looking no she wasn't
looking for porn i was saying the boys
were looking for porn
the girl was looking for okay more
important than money
yeah well oh my god
so your father used to keep
important things in his suit
pocket so you in the closet had a suit
and you would keep important things in
the suit pocket pretty tricky hide
things
yeah i never found that stuff okay
yeah well i did jessica
and you know your father and i were
healthy
normal sure young people absolutely
you know and we had a normal
don't say it sex life i knew where
you're going don't say that
and your father who's a little pervert
he's a little perverted no he's not
perverted he's a healthy
man you he's a pervert okay say that
about him your father wanted to take
pictures and there were no cell phones
oh my god oh my god so
yeah polaroid pictures
and your sister got into the closet
looked into dad's suit looking for cats
she's a good searcher
i can't believe she did this so she
comes up to me one
this is my many years later she was like
in junior higher high school
oh my god how horrifying oh my god so
years later she says to me mom i have to
confess something
and she told me i was horrified wait
what what what kind of photos are we
talking about i brought some
pictures we can't even go there you
brought some
i when when i was talking about like
graphic
oh yeah we're talking real great oh yeah
what is wrong with you guys
oh again these days right people never
use their i will
even i mean thank god we didn't have a
phone to probably be all over the
internet what's on your you don't have
that [ __ ] on your phone now dude no
no no no no that's another story all
together but we won't go why would you
guys have that you know
i made him burn those pictures you did
you burn them
i made them they got shredded actually i
like the burning oh no i just i could
not believe
that actually you made him burn them
after we found out
you know oh and we were gonna move and
he had those things this is before
jessica found out
and for some reason you had them under
your
under the mattress at first oh that's a
bat and then we were
moving and i said oh my god where do you
have those pictures
okay how many pictures are we talking
about like three or four or like
20 people no no no they're like four ten
maybe
ten there weren't that many
okay i think they were like four more
though and so jessica comes to you how
many years later
this was much later she was in her 20s
and she had she had to confess
and what was the tone of the confession
was it like uh
she goes you know i have to i have to
finally
confess she was holding on to something
really yeah she needed to spill her guts
somehow it really
you know terrorized her i don't think
she got
traumatic stress i don't think she got
past the first photo which is like oh
i'm disgusted i don't want to look at
anything oh my god
it sounds like the first photo was bad
enough oh my god it was horrible so
and so she was feeling like something
horrible and she needed to tell you
and how did you react well how would you
react i mean i was horrified
i went oh my god i just was i was
horrified
conversation i don't know a couple of
minutes
but it was long enough i was just [ __ ]
i was just horrified
mom used it oh my god what did you say
she used it
yes incorrect pronunciation yeah and
also you don't get the bonus
just trying to remind her no i just i
didn't i didn't
use the photographs i they were they
were they were
gone you guys have not are not saying it
right
anymore you guys have collectively
changed the pronunciation of the words
maybe for the better
i can't tell you they got kind of money
here
yees yeets no
i think we've gotten kanye in here
somehow uh
eat i knew there was a tea yeah
eats wow that is a really good story oh
my god
i cannot believe i actually told her our
older sister jessica is
10 years older than me so she's quite a
bit older so she has experiences that
are very different than mine and my
brothers because me and my brother
are two and a half years difference we
grow up together right
yeah i didn't know anything about this
oh i didn't that was something i held
real close to my channel that's way
worse than the dildo story isn't it uh
they're both yeah yeah definitely
because one is an article
one requires your imagination the other
does not require your imaginations
can i ask you guys a question did it
feature both of you guys
or one of you no don't even say anything
don't even
don't even go there don't even go
there here is what you saw no i don't do
that i draw the line no both bodies in
some manner
gary why did you even share that
so how did you take the photo was it on
auto timer it was a
color polaroid it was a pokemon but did
you do like a selfie or something
okay no no because then you're going to
get into what the photograph
is about i don't want to know what the
photograph is about trust me
allow us to demonstrate no hopefully you
know
speaking of hold on did you do a selfie
with the polaroid is that how you took
it
no no you just take a picture of
things that are happening but you said
both bodies were in it
okay let's not go there correct let's
not go there you guys
stop it's not that hard to figure out it
now
that's the way she can ever stop
oh my god i didn't know that
i didn't know that's where it was going
cut
cut it cut it oh my god so
look at see now we've we've traumatized
our other child
i warned you i have a story for you
it's about jessica also she wanted to
know where babies came from
was this before or after finding the
photo no this was yeah
no she wanted to know where babies came
from she said mom i really want to know
you know because we're learning about
this stuff in school and i don't get it
and so i said you really want to know
how old was she
i mean no i mean when is sex education
it's
in middle school probably 13. yeah it
was she was young yeah
like 13. yeah so i told her
exactly what a man has to do
right to make a baby absolutely and she
said
oh my god that means you've done it
twice
yeah mom said here jessica look at this
polaroid because
if you weren't born yet it was out of
our minds i know you guys burned the
physical copy but let's burn the mental
copy now please
okay that's pretty funny you know i have
a story to tell too
really uh oh uh oh well it's not about
me is it
i heard you guys doing it one time oh
god
because my bedroom it's not that bad i
was in the bedroom next to you guys at
our old house
and so i heard you guys it was like i
don't know six in the morning or
something and you guys were doing it
and i didn't look or anything i just
heard it and so i ran it to sean my
brother's bedroom
and i said sean we're gonna have another
mom's
have another baby because i thought it
was just one
shot right yeah and sean was like go
back to bed
that's not how it worked and i was so
shocked i was like what do you mean
they're having sex we're gonna have
another baby but i'm so excited not
that i was like so excited i was like i
think i told him i'm gonna be an older
brother
oh god that's so cute
in a weird way mangled with repulsive
sean was always ahead of his time there
and knowledge
knowledge yeah wow that is a really good
story mom
you brought the big guy oh god i'm proud
of you for bringing that out though
because i can't believe i said i shared
that
oh and oh ethan's
gonna pay for that story well you know
come on that you see celebrities
getting caught up in
the weird photos that come out i mean
you guys aren't celebrities you're my
parents no i don't know how
are you we're celebrities now what
what's your point is that other people
have
i mean it's it's not unusual for people
to
no i know you know no you're right
i just so just got to keep it it's just
safe
you just don't want your kids to find
things like that so dad you got one you
want to show all right it's your turn
oh okay let's have a break and then when
we come back my dad is going to share
the time
that he um
embarrassed myself yeah i was trying to
think of something funny but let's just
throw it to break
i've always wanted my skin to look like
my mom's
and sadly that will never happen i have
blackheads i'm greasy i'm dry
i'm watching i please
you think is that easy well i always
thought my goals were unattainable
but i've started using curology
okay now whether you're trying to take
control of acne or if acne is no longer
your top concern
fine lanes dark spots occasional
breakouts or clogged pores that's what i
have
do you see no my face oh you can't see
it i can't see it
look at the blackheads it's out of
control
here here here try their product i am
okay
it's working good unlike the washcloth
so listen curology will customize a
prescription formula with three active
ingredients picked for you to tackle
your skin care needs
you know the process of telling them
about your skin is really great and it
feels so personal
you tell you take out a survey you tell
them is your skin oily
is it dry i've my skin managed to be
both oily and dry at the same time how's
that possible a [ __ ] nightmare
um you send them some photos of your
skin so they can really get a
feel for what they're dealing with and
they customize
a plan and a treatment and boom they set
you up with a personalized
treatment plan that ships the custom
formula right to your door
um so obviously i've been i've only been
using it like a week
but i'm really excited because you know
going to a dermatologist and doing
such a pain in the ass but this is such
a great way to get that level of
personalized
care with this convenience you know
so take control of your acne dark spots
breakouts or whatever your unique
unique concerns may be with the powerful
skincare treatment made
for you today go to curology.com
h3 for a free 30-day trial just pay for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com
h3 to unlock your free 30-day
trial see curology.com for all the
details
i'm obsessed with oral hygiene brushing
flossing so important but here's
something that's
fun that you can do during the day that
dentists say is actually good for you
chewing gum ah doing gum is good for
your teeth
um i love chewing gum and with the right
kind of gum
you're gonna keep your mouth clean and
fresh all day long
beautiful uh you know it was only a few
years ago that quip who we loved
reinvented the toothbrush
dominated the industry with a beautiful
product they've done it again this time
for chewing gum
they've launched a new gum that's
actually good for your oral
waste it health of there whoa whoa
whoa it's yeah he eats seeds
does this have sugar in it no of course
not how dare how dare you
insinuate that whip that put sugar in
their gum
good right hmm so good
it's like crunchy wow i am
i love my gum as i smack into the
microphone
so they've launched a new gum that's so
good for you
comes with this fun dispenser you can
shoot people with i'll remind you that
the one-click candy you loved as a kid
is now very good for your teeth
clip gum can help prevent cavities and
freshen breath when chewed for 20
minutes after eating
it's sugar-free has tooth-friendly
xylithol with zero calories
and to satisfy your taste buds clip
added a long-lasting mint flavor
crunchy tri-layer design and stamped it
all with the classic
quip tongue it's slim travel ready
dispenser
with five different colors a packs and
protects up
ten pieces of gum at a time it fits into
just any purse or pocket on the go
and in a world where we all need to be
extra safe and hygienic
the quick the quick release button means
you can still share it with friends
no rapper hands or hassles that can't
blow a bubble
i think you need any more yeah okay you
want to try to blow some bubbles here
toss them both in there let's see what
you got is that a bubble tea
well let's see what you got don't don't
listen to haters add a gum refill plan
for a gift that keeps on giving all year
round
clips customizable subscription lets you
chew and share at your own pace
plus the more you buy the more you save
with both discounts on extra gum packs
come on people it's not a substitute for
brushing and flossing but it is a great
support for oral health pair with quip
electric toothbrush
refillable floss and more great products
right now special holiday deals
it fits great in stocking what year what
month do they think it is
in addition to gum packs footballs
delivers fresh breasts
brush heads floss toothpaste refills
every three months
from five dollars shipping is free you
can save money and skip the misery
of in-store shopping so head on over to
get quip dot com slash families right
now
and you'll get a free plastic dispenser
with any refill plan that's free
dispenser get quick.com families
that's g-e-t q-u-i-p dot com slash
families that's quipped the good habits
company
me undies believes that comfort is all
about what's touching the skin now
listen to me
i'm a big fat guy i don't have any
room for air when it comes to the space
down there if it's too tight if it's too
taut
if the fabric is not soft enough i'm
having a miserable day
and that's why i love me undies tell me
how soft that fabric is it's pretty soft
pretty soft yeah and i like the
you know what they have this is the
softest fabric
ever conceived by humanity and it's put
and it's
made specifically so that it can cradle
my junk and keep me comfortable and
breathable
well what did i just say that's wrong
all day long
okay they've got these great ridiculous
prints it's super fun you can express
yourself
they go from extra small to 4xl
it's basically the best undies in the
game dad i dare you to put those on
you'll never want another pair again
you're going to never leave your couch
again with the meundies membership a
monthly subscription that sends new
pairs right to your door
each month you'll choose new new undies
socks and bralettes
pick the styles and colors or prints
that feel the most to you fun
right yeah exactly enjoy also enjoy a
discounted pricing free shipping and
exclusive early access
to new launches love your butt get the
membership
i like the the legs how they have it on
the legs
that's probably too big for you huh
small uh
yeah probably but you know what you
won't get a panty line
pantyline yeah what's it say what a
panty line
what's a panty line oh you're such a guy
well like when you wear underwear
sometimes you get lots
of fanny line yeah oh so what you wear
thongs
i do oh my god am i
does you asked why do you need to wear a
thong i always wear cuz
you're an old lady wear some underwear
okay well until meundies makes thongs my
mom will uh his aunt
is uh protesting i like this it's not
like you see a panty line and you go oh
oh i can't believe i see a pen i know
you're wrong what a trashy woman you
can't see a panty line with these
oh you're saying you won't yeah oh okay
okay
yeah beautiful no they're good okay put
that away
all right
anyway they're great meundies has a
great offer for my listeners any first
time purchase you get 15
off from free shipping me undies also
has their problem free
philosophy if you're not satisfied with
any product for any reason
they'll refund or exchange it no caveats
no questions
boom that's great get 15 off your first
order and free shipping go to
meundies.com
families that's meundies.com
families honey honey
honey honey girl we love
honey we all shop online we've seen
promo con
codes taunting us at the checkout and
it's such a pain in the ass when you
go you're shopping online and you know
those discount codes out there
but you're just not finding them and it
eats you and it ruined your online
shopping experience
that's where honey comes in it searches
the internet
at checkout on like over 30
000 stores online basically everything
when you're at checkout getting ready to
buy your [ __ ] honey goes no stop it i'm
a friend like a good designated driver
they say
stop don't shop without honey don't
drive while you're under the influence
right
so they take you by the hand they say
i'm going to check the internet for you
you know in a matter of seconds they
their eyes roll white
they're in the matrix boom they go we
found coupons here's the best one
automatically no questions asked
immediate it's
insanely useful they are on all the
stores ranging from tech gaming products
fashion brands food delivery it's
everywhere
you know excellent all you have to do is
click apply coupon
at checkout it's as easy as two clicks
it's just a browser
it's freaking amazing i love honey me
and either save my
money all the time when we're shopping
you know you
you going out shopping a lot of times it
happens with clothing
and she doesn't even know she's missing
out on an opportunity until honey swoops
in it's like oh 50
off these 200 jeans that's great i was
like cha-ching
you know did you know this honey has
saved
its 17 million members over two
billion dollars whoa yeah that's enough
to
for that's enough to do a space race
with jeff bezos
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up
missing out on free savings it's
literally free
and installs in just a few seconds and
by getting it you're going to be doing
yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast we love that
about you i would never recommend
something i don't use and trust me i use
and i love honey
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
families that's join honey dot com
families we are back from break thank
you for watching dad do you have a story
for us
i might be able to come up with one can
you top that
i had a lame one that i was gonna do but
since mom was so forthcoming
with her embarrassing story i'm going to
go with the
actually more embarrassing one oh what
oh this goes back to
mid 70s i think i was in outside sales
for a large carpet manufacturer
so my job was driving up and down the
coast
from like glendale all the way up to
paso robles
calling on accounts it was a good job a
lot of driving but you know good
relationship building uh anyway one of
the clients of this company
uh i knew a bunch of people there
uh they were one one of the women that
worked i remember
kelly who worked at a i do um
her father was one of the four
founders of some company called ibm
and they had a house in hidden hills
yeah that was
beautiful house first time i'd ever been
in there and
it coincided with the muhammad ali
leon spinks fight and they had a
bartender there and everything and
and so was for dinner and drinks and
i've never been good at knowing my limit
with alcohol
like they invited the carpet salesman to
the party
well i i knew people at the party my
boss was invited
also so it was a bunch of people in the
carpet industry like
the carpet companies the three companies
that they were the closest with got
invited along with so it was
kind of industry and friends party no
spouses were invited because i wasn't
at that party i don't know this might
have been
seventies i know i knew when you worked
there
no i know but we were separated for part
of it also so
whatever the circumstances were anyway
covered 30 year old beef possibly
they bartenders there and i start
drinking
tanqueray tonics just to enough is it
the fact that it's free
that you push yourself too far because i
know you have a passion for
free things free is good
free always tastes good you have this
you have this need of like
it's free i need to get as much as
possible that's
human nature i think well i don't know
if that's human nature
it's that's that scary nature your
father doesn't know his limits when it
comes to alcohol
yeah so i have a hard time walking that
line between
wow i'm feeling really good and wow the
room is spinning
so uh had drinks the fight was on
ali lost shocking upset
and keep drinking we go sit down for
dinner
and all of a sudden i'm not feeling very
good and
i excuse myself and i stumble into the
bathroom
and start uh what are they praying at
the
porcelain throne there yeah so i you
know on
loosen my tie and i'm all dressed up you
know uh and just start
hurling into the toilet and i ended up
passing out
oh my god in the bathroom you've never
told me this
oh all these all my peers from the
industry
and my boss and all these other such a
degenerate
and just like passed out for 30 minutes
or so i think and then
clearly sheepishly came out at the end
yes there's a chapter i would like to
not remember but did anybody comment on
your disappearance do people know what
was happening
oh well yeah i just wasn't there no no
one really said anything
aside from pitiful glances i think
and i'm sure it it's terrible echoed
through the industry i was in
you know what a fool i made of myself so
that was a good embarrassing story that
was it yeah that was bad that was worse
than
falling off my shoes huh well hold on
so you come back you sit back down at
the table and resume dinner
or did you not leave everybody was done
i think it was like time to leave
so you come out you're probably still
like pissed drunk right
not as much but yeah i mean from there
the details get kind of fuzzy like i
don't know
i think how did you get home i think art
my boss
drove me home i think he didn't give you
any words of uh
again i don't remember now almost
blackout drunk but
that probably would have been better but
uh your father does that
you know when we were younger we went
somewhere and you got
so drunk that in the middle of the night
you
you opened up the closet thinking it was
the bathroom and threw up
all over your shoes readily puking story
is
not true well my dad for the record does
not drink
so nope yeah he's not an alcoholic right
he's just very lightly on occasion
and very heavily as others pass over
yeah yeah yeah very yummy
wow that yeah you're total degenerate i
mean
geez nice you didn't get fire you didn't
lose your job or anything
no i can't believe you never told me
that story
it's embarrassing i saved it to tell
two million people watching on the
internet i know
i like your story about your when you
worked at the department store
well that was less embarrassing let's
hear it
while we're on the topic oh great i'm
not going to have any embarrassing
stories
left this is an hour never okay just
tell this story
you know what you're gonna just blow
your load like you're on team
skeet team what
team ski i was working at uh yo did you
really make me
uh repeat team ski are you being paid
off by them to for me to mention them on
the show
not that you're aware of you have a back
deal going on
i do not that i'm aware of exactly what
they wanted out of that care package
another box of goodies coming i was not
going to mention it
she brought it up if you recall that's
true
right i said cut it was funny though
anyway i was working
at uh what used to be
broadway which is now macy's in the
northridge fashion
center uh which was destroyed in the
northridge earthquake and i grew up
uh literally a half a mile from the
northridge fashion center and watched it
get built piece by piece anyway
uh working at macy's working i don't
even remember what department i was in
but uh i was a little bigger and more
fit and
uh back in those days big
platform shoes were popular for everyone
including men
so like boots had big heels on them
i'm working the register and a guy comes
up kind of suspicious looking guy
gives me a credit card pays and you get
that
warning message you know like it's a
code three so then you're supposed to
you know stall
and wait for security and they have like
a warning that it's like probably fraud
right
oh so you know they give out this you
know
security to section blah blah blah uh
you know so i'm trying to keep the guy
calm and yeah
boy this machine is so slow and all of a
sudden he gets
hinky and bolts for the door
now the correct thing dude would say i
don't care what
i don't own macy's whatever go goodbye
good luck
no so i go chasing after him so he runs
out the door
into the parking lot i go running after
him in the parking lot
as i run off the curb
my heel hits and twists and i just
go down in a heap sprained my ankle so
bad miss work for a week walked around
on crutches
so that was embarrassing anyone thank
you for your valiant effort
mr macy actually called mr mr broadway i
said
sir we appreciate the effort but you're
gonna have to miss week
uh miss a week of work so you're fired
that's right we don't pay workers comp
either yeah
no i yeah it worked out that's not that
important that's more like you
glorifying how heroic you are
why was a relic yeah oh it's
embarrassing to fall off your shoes
not as embarrassing as the first story
nothing horrifying that was horrifying
you're holding on to the really deep
dark [ __ ] that was pretty dark about it
mom didn't even know of that one so yeah
okay very good thank you guys for
sharing
was our pleasure
my mom took out the new she dropped the
big nuclear bomb on that was
that was nuclear that was definitely you
might say you
yeed it out of the park yeah
cha-ching hold on i don't know if that's
right you said
you might say you yited it out of the
park
yeah you eat it you said you eat it well
ye did
like eddie can you put it easy after
that
come on i know it's a little contrived
isn't it all right
you gotta really use it naturally we
can't say okay
we needed it out of the park with that
one after every sentence
i did not prompt her either yeah all
right too
i'll give it to you yeah pay attention
woman all right i'm talking about
lunch here okay nice lunch
all right well do you guys want to share
your controversial opinions
um i'll do mine because yours are funny
mine are kind of serious
should i do that go ahead okay oh more
notes
without notes okay so this is
well i don't know they're both kind of
controversial let me see this here let
me see
back and forth back and yeah front and
back
okay what is this thirty four thousand
per year
okay okay okay so the first thing a lot
of people
are for capital punishment yeah a lot of
people aren't
yeah people go back and forth and back
and forth and then there's
there's financial reasons you're going
to say kill all prisoners
no that would be very euthanize all
criminals no
i'm i'm against the death penalty
wow which is i don't know is that real
controversial
people are it is kind of controversial
for some reason because some people
and it's ironic they're usually like
christians right wing
conservative types that go praise god
kill kill kill they're pro-life yeah
yeah
so only when it applies to the woman no
i'm very anti-capital punishment
you know i mean when people use the
excuse that
you know it costs a lot of money to kill
someone
oh my mom's coming with the stats
watching yeah okay
so in california per year what we spend
on a prisoner is thirty four thousand
one hundred and fifty dollars
that's so that's that's to house and you
know all that other stuff
to kill somebody
we've spent uh over the the average cost
of 11
executions in the past 27 years was 250
million dollars for how many executions
11. it's mostly wait why because
of the legal expenses because you're
entitled to because
of these guys and it appeals right when
you are sentenced to the death penalty
but the
public opinion really ebbs and flows on
that and
250 million 250 million
the is the average cost of 11 executions
and that's been in the past 27 years in
california
hasn't killed anyone in i said in the
past 27 years [ __ ] insane
that is so like the moral issue of of
putting sentencing someone to death
is a whole different argument but like
it's wasting that much money
and this is another thing that i thought
was really interesting we ain't got
money for schools but we got money for
executions boy
woo so the average age
of someone that's executed yeah what do
you think it would be
they're probably old because they sit in
jail for a long time 49 years old
yeah that's the average i'm feeling like
it you know 49
leave them alone we'll just get them in
jail if they're a danger to society
life without the chance of performing
right right my problem with the x with
the death sentence is that
there's always going to be a small
chance that they're actually innocent
and we've seen this time and time again
over
if you're black yeah yeah it's applied
so unevenly
that uh you know your chances
you know if you're just a average white
person you commit a murder
right you know chances are
african-americans or black americans
are sentenced to death much at a much
higher frequency well yeah
they're subject to all kinds of things
much more than than your
white person but like how is anybody
okay
with the prospect of us as a society
condemning an innocent person to death
well you know
my dad used to say to me i would rather
let
27 people go than to accidentally kill
one person 27
why 20 yeah i do is that just a carpet
like a bike salesman why is he having
this no i mean we were talking
i remember talking to my father we we
used to sit around they had moonlight as
a batman or something
my dad and my my family when we were
young
you know before even i met dad we used
to sit around
at dinner and talk politics i don't know
i just threw the expression is a hundred
yeah but he would he would let he would
he would say he would rather let all
these people go
that's very wise that's what they say is
the
um that's what they say about justice
right is better
that's why the the uh reasonable doubt
is there because it's better to let
better to free a hundred guilty men yes
and then let one innocent guy an
innocent man to death yeah
and we see it all the time dna comes out
twenty years later yeah
guys have been in prison 20 30 years and
sometimes when the dna comes out they
still won't let them go which i don't
understand
but the whole thing of even and then
even further is like
obviously we all agree that murdering is
uh immoral
so who is the state to make that like
like it's especially ironic because
again it's these conservative religious
states so the one doing all the
executions it's like
get your morals in order is murdering
okay or not if it's not
you can't murder someone you should not
kill people and to prove that we're
going to kill you exactly
for killing exactly it's it's literally
just you know mass
mass murder is kind of a it looks you
know
so there's a cocktail that they use to
murder somebody
because uh lethal injection is how
you know 29 states in our union
kill people how else do they still kill
people in like crazy old school yeah
that's why i think
you talk people utah just allowed you
to choose hanging and or firing squad if
you prefer
i don't think well let me tell you
alabama arkansas being thrown off a
cliff run over by a car
yeah i'd rather get shot in the head
it's instant
so alabama arkansas oklahoma
south carolina tennessee utah wyoming
it's not legal to uh to
uh have lethal injection they don't
allow it they don't allow it
there's three things that they that in
this cocktail sodium
uh penitent or it's pino
barbitol ultras anyway we don't need
that
into the weeds they give you an
anesthetic that knocks you out
yeah they give you something that stops
you from breathing and then the other
one gives you a heart attack
but some people survive this right
which is horrible to walk i can't
imagine watching
i've read about the cocktail apparently
one component makes you paralyzed
and the other like uh makes your heart
stop right and apparently
if you don't lose consciousness it's
extremely painful
and painful yeah you just sit there
paralyzed unbeknownst and just
die of this horrible agonizing death and
sometimes they have to do it again oh
that's crazy yeah just shoot him in the
[ __ ] head
it's like dude let's not let's not mince
words here you're killing somebody
not try to act like it's all beautiful
i'd rather just have someone
straight you know i mean you're not
going to survive that
no well firing squad but don't think
she's in the chest
well firing squad you can miss yeah pick
your spot
i would just take a gun and just shoot i
want to drop them for my
i want to be thrown off a cliff you
should be able to if you're going to
kill them they should be able to choose
the way they die
thrown to some sharks i don't know yeah
skydiving accident i don't know but do
you know it costs 200
for a an injection each injection
200 bucks yeah it costs 200 you're
saying that the comparison of the cost
of the injection compared to the actual
cost
of executing someone is is that's what's
interesting about the price of it well
yeah i mean you know when you talk about
when people say oh the cost of keeping
someone alive there's so many
costs of when they're on death row
let's get the serum out and just start
killing people no i'm against it because
it costs two well you said it's 200
bucks it seems like a good deal compared
to keeping someone in jail
yeah yeah i'm just saying it costs money
to kill someone
it costs money to kill someone it's only
200 bucks that's a good ass deal
well okay i don't get your point that's
a
value good value that's only one thing
just
added it added up it's a lot of money
maybe controversy on some circles but
i've
i am 100 with you mom abolish the
capital punishment politicians we are
we have to decide we have to decide who
we are are we murderers are we not
murderers
period yeah i think public opinion has
swung back
into the majority people being against
the death penalty
where the majority people were were pro
death penalty maybe
10 years ago put them in a cell swing
back and put them in a hole
put them in a solitary confinement
you know like like charles manson when
we put him in holes
in a whole no that would be fun no you
can't do that and of course trump
at the end of his uh alleged presidency
management
he managed to execute 10
12 people in the last six months just
like well we got these people on death
row
let's kill them all and there hadn't
been any federal executions in
yeah i heard about years and i thought
some of those guys had uh
at least a few of them had questionable
mm-hmm
uh stances yeah know
uh contravening evidence yeah he does
that to appease the christians we love
jesus
number one don't kill people let's kill
him
let's kill them all right dad what's
yours
um i have a
couple one being uh
a word to people who
aren't getting vaccinated oh no here we
go
and their excuse is
you know the fda hasn't approved this
yet and i'm not sure about it so
i'm gonna wait and see you know
what happens um
so you know what they're really saying
is
when all you guinea pigs we're gonna see
how the rest of you do and if all the
rest of you are okay
then i feel it's safe for me and
you know i i think that kind of attitude
is so contrary
to what america is supposed to be about
e pluribus unum it's on our money
it means uh from many one
[Laughter]
meaning everyone should put
all of their differences all their
hostilities aside and work for a common
goal we're one country
eradicating a deadly pandemic but
because there's so many unvaccinated
people still
heavily republican and heavily red
states
um you see this the new variant
coming back states are trending up
medium in california here we've got the
the devin nunes uh parts of the state
uh where people are getting sick again
so uh get with it people it's safe
uh something like 99
of people who are dying of cove but now
aren't
vaccinated how much more proof so a
conservative
would say to you dad you're vaccinated
it protects you
why do you care what i do because
your actions have a bearing on everyone
else
if you catch covid and you give it to
someone else
all those medical costs are being born
by all of us it's like the arguments
oh i'm a libertarian i don't want to
wear a seat belt i can't wear a
motorcycle helmet well
you know the problem with all those
arguments is the the public at whole
bears the cost for all these people who
want to be irresponsible
at no cost to themselves dad what do you
say to the conservative that says you're
just being a sheep
you're saying you don't want to you want
to be a guinea pig
well yeah that makes you a sheep you're
the guinea pig
and they're the wolf well i'm a guinea
pig that's not gonna get
covered and you're a wolf that probably
is gonna get covered
so you admit your sheep no i'm using
their
figure of speech i make
independent decisions based upon the
best possible evidence
and the overwhelming evidence okay let
me ask you this checkmate question
do you watch rachel maddow yes or no
yes i can do it busted
yeah we do we watch cnn and then well
but then i watched tucker klansman
so yeah you know what this morning
dad and i were watching the news and
they were discussing
uh the talking heads if you will they
were discussing
when we used to uh you know when polio
was alive and well and when they first
came up with the serum how everybody
celebrated and was like lining up to get
their shots and that um
the news organization was so much more
simple
you know you had walter cronkite you had
fewer
you know you didn't have the social
media and you didn't have fox news
promoting all these lies for political
purposes which makes
no sense at all because you're telling
people
like tucker carlson has been vaccinated
and yet he gets
on his channel and tells people not to
do it
so if you're telling someone else not to
do it
why are you vaccinated well he has an
idea
publicly that he's very helpful no he is
not publicly admitted yeah he hasn't
publicly admitted it but
uh people that know him
okay i'm telling you i'm about to i'm
like about to get my second cease and
desist letter so that
keeps this off about carl taco tuckelson
yeah well well we call him carl tucks
the dick between the legs
tucker klansman i like that one i don't
know thank you
okay i mean okay you guys are coming
with some political takes i was thinking
more like so mine for example was that i
don't like pasta
you guys have anything maybe a little
less chocolate
yeah i i rise in defense
of season eight of game of thrones
[Laughter]
that's a good one now you're gonna get
cancelled how do you defend that [ __ ]
how
go ahead i hate the ending i hate to to
defend
that dog [ __ ] [ __ ] mutilated
aborted fetus of a [ __ ] it's so bad
it ruined the whole series how do you
really
feel so [ __ ] half it's not even half
baked it's not even cooked i mean it's
just dog [ __ ]
go ahead okay the last episode i will
grant
was it seemed like a real easy and
convenient way
to work things out you say what are you
talking about say something
you defending yeah but season eight was
a lot more than
just the final episode i know i watched
every god yeah but the last
episode is what ruined it no no no no no
it's all bad
go ahead no it's not no i i i mean
there was great stuff there we had the
the uh
the battle there with all the uh walkers
coming
and them defending uh what's your
majigger
oh this is a great defense
that was a great episode you're talking
about when daenerys destroyed the whole
red keep with the dragon what are you
talking about
no when the army of the dead attacked
winterfell
at the very end there went so he went
charging out there and
you just it was so dumb they built up
the night king
all season long right he literally
amounted to
nothing no motivation no backstory it
was way too easy
nothing and then this deuce shows up and
nobody gives a [ __ ]
jon snow is just kind of like rolling
around and
[ __ ] being a dumbass or piece of [ __ ]
he's the chosen one you do [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden arya's like oh
i got a [ __ ] dagger and it's like
literally all this buildup for nothing
literally unfathomably
dumb and ruinous disagree first jon snow
was trapped by
one of them
to defend the world he was the hero of
light he's not a little [ __ ] supposed
to be trapped in the [ __ ] corner
in the meantime pointless the whole
curve of the show
arya spent training for this
she was the assassin great scene where
she fought
uh what's her name the gwendolyn
christie
she was training to be an assassin sure
she had an interesting story lined up
for but everything came to nothing
because
the whole prophecy that we're all meant
to believe in there was
no notion the whole series that this
prophecy was going to go askew
or that was arya it was literally just
[ __ ] right be on [ __ ] writing
[ __ ] aborted writing hap it was just
this writing was has as is just
mutilated and [ __ ] well dan and dave
would disagree with that
i didn't like the jon snow killed uh
okay no one liked that he killed who
died
yeah daenerys gives a [ __ ] the whole
thing was literally
doesn't exist in my mind the whole it
doesn't it's help
dan do you have an opinion on this oh
yeah i i hated it as well i'm
i'm with this side of the room i'm sorry
gary and brandon
nothing the whole show yeah that's a
total piece of okay
cool oh the [ __ ] the one-eyed rave
three-eyed raven he's like i'm king
[ __ ]
what's up now yeah like he was
prophesizing the whole time he could see
the future
and all he was doing was scheming to be
king like what the [ __ ]
pointless dumb horrible i wish that
episode was never even made
well what about when bran got out of his
wheelchair at the end and fought the
night king
what wait that didn't happen that might
have been a better ending
instead of just sitting there like a
bump on a log
the whole series he was you know it
doesn't it didn't make any sense
brandon would be the king there's
nothing redeeming that season was beyond
repair i like the last episode of lost
too so i never watched that show
that that was also my dad reversion
okay that's easy to entertain that's my
take
i've got definitely controversial so i
applaud you for that yeah
dan and dave if you want to reach out to
me personally and thank me
they got so greedy they're like oh hbo
is gonna give us a show
and then they made they ended the show
so poorly that i think hbo took
they recanted their offer well they were
supposed to go do a star wars movie
right yeah and they're like [ __ ] you you
suck
they took it back they're not doing [ __ ]
now how many years did that
game of thrones what was it like seven
years eight
seasons it's just but it was every other
year it was
ten years i think i mean to end it like
that
after all of that with the actors had to
deal
with weather they stomped on my face and
i'm not into that kind of thing
it was so good apparently my dad
apparently isn't that type of thing i
don't know
if you go back and watch the first
season the pacing
the character development everything was
so beautiful so amazing
and like as you build up you have all
these wonderful plots that are coming to
diverge
and then it's diverging and they just go
[ __ ] everything
horrible worst show worst ending to a
show ever by far
yeah in fact it's so bad that i can no
longer enjoy the show i can't even go
back and re-watch it because i know
it doesn't go in right right well it was
it was really
entertaining it was an amazing show
everyone couldn't wait
i was so invested you know everybody was
and then at the last
that last show just you know and when
daenerys came out and the wings were
behind her and you thought
oh this is going to be what an awesome
and then just when he goes down the
stairs and
he just yates right into into oblivion
he hates
what about jamie and cersei did that
work hold on we have to analyze
well first of all you said it wrong
it's not great yet yes yes
okay yeet into oblivion do we accept
that dan
uh because you eat something i said it
right but i
didn't pronounce it right you're saying
that the the creators of the show
yeeted the quality of the show into
oblivion no no no no no no she's saying
deniro is
generic dad you know she came out and
she was it was epic and then
from there the whole show just no no no
you were saying she was on a dragon and
she yeted herself to the city
no no that's not what i said that's not
what she said so go ahead and rephrase
that
rephrase the eat now i don't remember
exactly how i said it i i remember what
she said i
i i i'd give it to her i'll give that to
her but she said yeast
or something well except that yeah
that's your call
dance my friend we're gonna give you a
100
bonus today for that yeast yeah yeasted
themselves
25 for you their dancing deniro okay so
daenerys is descent into madness while
an interesting plot point
was so [ __ ] rushed i couldn't
possibly believe
that the amount of [ __ ] that she's been
through her whole life and then this
small little [ __ ] blip
has has turned her to has caused her to
turn into this
murderous psychopath it's just
if you're gonna do that big of a
character shift you need to
tell give it the justice it deserves and
for those reasons there's nothing
redeeming about that season and shame on
you
i agree but that now that's a good
controversy i'll take though
fantastic so here i've got something i
want to show you
there's a whole conspiracy theory about
justin bieber
you know justin bieber is married to
haley
baldwin baldwin's niece oh he is
yeah oh and so there's all these little
clips online
of him being an ass to his wife
and so i want to show you each one of
these clips how old is this guy
how old is justin mid-20s yeah probably
and so i'm going to show 27. so i'm
going to show you this clip
okay and you tell me is justin being an
ass
or is it overblown or
is it out of context okay but there's
vast conspiracy theories
so here we go let's start from the first
one passive aggressive
on an instagram live ooh passive
aggressive here we go okay let's see
please you know like it sucks that the
tour was
you just answered my favorite she was
asking me
huh
anyways you're asking me because it's my
lyme disease it's not your lyme disease
are you
worried about my lyme disease well i was
helped you know in
every freaking day in the doctor with
you for months
yeah but sometimes they ask if i was
scared about the lyme disease because
i'm the one that has it right but i i
didn't say that i just was saying that
you were taking all the
listen to me woman yeah that's the
attitude
thoughts ass
overblown or out of context
justin bieber root so somebody asked
this is so funny that the shit's out
there yeah
somebody asked him about his lyme
disease right she answered
he didn't like that it's his lyme
disease right
not her lyme disease right it all seemed
in pretty good nature honestly yeah i
think it was taken out of context
really his face looks pretty bitter like
no he obviously was annoyed i have a
habit of doing that today
who doesn't get annoyed with their
significant other look at dad's head
shaking
i've seen you guys fight like that every
day much worse what
when i was a kid you guys were going big
boy
it was brutal never fought in our entire
marriage is no i you know people get
annoyed with one another okay so we're
writing this off
yeah yeah overblown oh totally over
overblown okay
interesting because this clip has gone
viral we've been married for so many
years right it's like come on
did you get it anything short of
punching her in the face my dad's like
it's fine
no i'm kidding i'm kidding no i think it
was overblown
okay that's interesting because on
this clip has gone viral and a lot of
people saying
justin's going too far well here's
another one okay this is very
interesting actually to get you guys
perspective
here's another one justin bieber with
the paparazzi
okay okay here's the title justin bieber
treated haley like garbage
what a disgrace of my dad standing in
front of the camera
go ahead no dad stand in front of the
camera that's a good shot yeah stand in
front of the camera
for real i want to see what the shot
looked like
um okay here we go
obviously much too loud dan
so one more time if you missed it he
closes the door on her
yeah they had a fight as they're getting
out of the car but even after having a
fight i mean
what once again the title
what a garbage piece of garbage what a
disgrace
good morning
oh there's more this is a whole
compilation
so now this is one where he runs across
the street and leaves her behind well
here let's talk about situational
what do we think about closing the door
i think it's childish ass yeah
yeah i think i think it's childish i
think it's ridiculous i mean
husbands and wives at any age are they
going to ask
they're going to get they're going to
get pissed and
and uh can't close and his
you know it's just immature and it has
nothing to do with him having money or
being
spo well it has something to do with him
being spoiled but
that's a passive aggre no it's not even
passive aggressive that's just
aggressive dad what do we think about
closing the door on haley i think it's
rude
not good manners clearly they had had
some kind of fight
in the car unanimous ruling she's all
disheveled looking and
clearly none of them are neither of them
are real happy at this point
okay but you don't have to close the
door in her face well especially in
front of paparazzi
right you know okay he's an ass
we're gonna have to make a ruling at the
end of this if we think he's an ass
okay we'll add it up yeah okay so
there's one against him here's another
one coming up
he's running across the street leaving
her behind he's skateboarding across the
street
and here she is being forced to run
after him
in busy times square
why is he doing that what's the what's
this
all i know is that he bailed on his wife
on skateboard left her to fend for
herself she trips and has to chase him
across the street
one more time he's like peace out
everybody including my wife
go ahead trip you know oh my god i have
to
runs after him okay
i'll give you some thoughts and it
happens with a lot of men
say you're going somewhere and the the
uh
the the male is is like rushing to the
movie theater
we'll use that as an example and the
female
is maybe she they've made it her they've
made them
a little late or whatever and so he
takes off for the theater and she has to
catch up and run after him
my thinking is you know what what are
you going to do go into the
you're going to pay for both tickets why
are you running ahead
you have to wait for them so what are
you running ahead for what is
the passive aggression it's totally
passive aggressive i think that's
ridiculous
oh an ass a brutal ass rating for my mom
on that one
definitely dad is it better he's gone
from
aggressive to passive aggressiveness it
is an upgrade sure
the next one so do we we
i think we uh i was against him i
personally would definitely give that an
ass rating i mean i won't even do that
to my friend let alone my wife
because the situation that they're in
they're being hounded by paparazzi
it's clearly an unsafe and stressful
situation
and they're in the middle of times
square was a really bustling crazy place
to be
so not only does he bail he leaves her
in the trenches
to run after him probably in high heels
he takes off on the skateboard i mean
that's ass
yeah total with the big capital a
all right next one
[Music]
okay one more time he seems to point
and slap her in the face what here we go
one more time now
whoa whoa
i'd be calling my divorce attorneys
right now
right now well hold on don't don't rush
to judgment it could have been an
accident
it could be that they were joking around
it could be that he was actually
pointing
okay that's true but let's just let's
analyze let's watch the whole thing
i'm gonna put on slow
where are they coming from is that a
restaurant yeah it looks like they're
it's an ice cream store
yeah okay they're coming from eating it
looks like
okay here we go one more time now don't
blink
that looks like it's it's it's it's uh
intentional
it looks like a karate chop to the face
almost yeah it looks like
are we sure he even made contact maybe
he's kidding maybe it's like hey
come on chop to the face like good old
times yeah i
don't think he even made contact and she
just kind of
fled like she was playing along with it
i don't think there was no no
no no no no no he meant to hit her
so is there any situation where one of
these is like hey credit jump to the
head
no beautiful wife
time to call the attorneys wow
i'm sorry there's no reason for for any
kind of physical body maybe she ate some
of his ice cream
i think walmart has
got an issue one more time now we're
gonna get a close-up here
we're gonna see this in slow motion
oh nope we're done so we're rolling ass
on this
yeah yeah he's got he's got four stars
against them not only are we calling him
this and ass we're calling this called
the divorce attorney
i wow i'm done i'm i'd be done
that's it here's one of him justin
screaming at haley in an arcade oh my
god i don't know if i've seen this one
again this looks like an instagram story
that he one of them posted so
take that in mind i won accept it
wow okay
wow take all things into consideration
they posted this on instagram so maybe
they they clearly thought it was funny
is it possible that he was joking
because he was really having a meltdown
why would they post it
who she posted it somebody posted it
says i want to accept it so it's clearly
they posted it somewhere probably
instagram stories
let's watch it one more time i mean it
depends on who posted it
yeah she did well you think she was
exposing him
i think they both have got problems i
think that she's
she should just walk away if she's not
happy instead of
calling calling out her husband she
should just walk away
you know
maybe i wasn't trying i beat you
accepted
dude if he's not joking that is like
such an amazing meltdown over arcade
basketball
oh she kicked his ass look at that score
wow oh he wasn't trying dad don't say
that
baby i want to try
i i mean what do you think dan is this a
meltdown or a childish if it's a gag
it's not a good one because he looks too
serious
and then at the end he's pouting one
more time one more time this is good
it doesn't look like he's kidding i have
to say it sounds pretty exasperated
why would you play it play and not try i
let you beat me
he doesn't look like he's kidding dan
what do you think
i mean the tone of her voice sounds
playful which
makes me lean a little bit more towards
he's just [ __ ] around
but i mean we did just also watch four
other clips of him being an [ __ ] to
her so
you know it's hard to not let that
influence your perception of it
can you actually get that mad over
arcade basketball oh well i
i don't lose so
[Laughter]
amazing yeah i don't know so we rating
ass on this one or possible
i i i don't know if it's an if it's an
ass that i would it's another baby
that was nice yeah well yeah that was an
affectionate like
i don't know i don't know isn't that a
justin bieber song
it is baby baby
okay moving on there's quite a lot of
these so i'm saying there's this is a
baby geez
yeah i know who is he dating before he
got married
[Music]
so this one is um justin
uh not wanting to be touched
just honest babe i just i can't don't
touch me right now like not right now
but i'm just
i thought you were serious no no no no
no no no no just in general
that just happened sometimes you just
just said that
he's asked she's putting her hands
around lovingly saying babe don't touch
me right now
although he seems to be doing it
respectfully
he's setting a boundary uh for for you
know
apparently don't touch him you know like
all marriages
or not maybe just not i mean
there's times like if it's really hot
you know it's not that's not
that was not that was not one of those
times without
love it seems like two 12 year olds that
are married
i mean neither of them seem to have the
maturity necessary
hold on i haven't seen haley doing
anything wrong i got to stand up for her
a little bit i don't know why she's
getting thrown under the bus
who threw her under the bus well dad you
said they both seem immature
no dad just said they both look like 12
year olds i never called her immature
he's got problems well but that doesn't
mean that she's immature
i'm team haley well i
would lean towards haley also so what do
we think about this
it could just be the thing is justin has
had
justin's been through a lot in his short
life he got lyme disease also that
heavily affected him
so you know it's it's possible sometimes
he gets moody
how did he get lyme disease you know
no i know you get it from a tick but i
don't know is he out
respect writing or something you get
bitten by a deer tick
what am i a scheduler maybe it was
hiking
i don't know so this is a pretty serious
disease okay let's move on to the next
one yeah it can be it's just it really
is a horrible disease
dead and i had a friend who had it she
was paralyzed
moving away from her at a ball game oh
oh
this sounds very spicy
justin bieber is here as well
you know him not liking to be touched
and
right now it seems to me like he feels
smothered
right but i don't i mean
okay but like it's just his wife
well first of all they're making maybe
maybe it's annoying
that she's you know constantly like
you know it's like all right already
we're they're making assumptions about
what he said but it does look like he
said
he said don't touch me don't touch me
and then she's like oh [ __ ]
i mean i don't know it's just hard to be
i don't know i think that sometimes if
you someone is
constantly you know but they're made all
over
it's not like a clingy girlfriend
they're married well he is canadian
in his defense i'm not sure what that
means yeah what does that mean
this one's ambiguous though what do you
think about this one
i don't know if it's right or wrong i
just watching
these clips i just get the feeling that
he does not he's being smothered in his
mind or
how he's you know either can smother me
i like when she smothers me yeah he just
comes off looking down
in all of these i think i'm very needy
if you marry someone you're saying you
can smother me you have my consent to
smother me that's what marriage is yeah
i'm always smother me more
please i need someone to touch me don't
touch me i'm touching me i am deeply
insecure
please touch me or i will cry
team touch me all right settle down over
there team skeet
[Laughter]
you're on too many teams today that's
true okay and the final one
is justin yelling at haley in public
that's not good when he found out the
peaches weren't from georgia
i get my way from california oh here we
don't need the music
here here he is walking by okay let me
take a look and he's going oh
looking angry oh my now reports
uh i've heard reports that apparently
this was after his show his first show
back in a long time right and he was
just hyped
does this look like hype to you or anger
well sometimes it's hard to tell okay
he's not very tall is he looking i've
met him
two of them are compared to everybody
else's [ __ ] he's like six foot
no that was no way i'm telling you i've
met him in person
named girls girls were high heels person
[Music]
he was backstage at a post malone
concert when we were there oh they're
friends aren't they yes
and post malone is the sweetest guy ever
he's so sweet
yeah he's great so okay
so what's the verdict here what do we
think so on let's see
how much trouble is haley and let's say
on a scale of one to ten one being
you're in a loving relationship you have
nothing to worry about
five being
and ten being get out
you know marriage
is a rollercoaster and sometimes
you're in a state in your relationship
where everything is
perfect and happy and you can't get
enough of each other and then there's
times in the decline when you
bicker a lot and you just oh my god you
just
argue and don't get along and then it
passes so
you know that's the thing about
relationships there is not everything
isn't just smooth sailing and
and perfect and it's tough for them too
i mean these are intimate moments caught
by paparazzi who are pounding them all
the time right so you know that's tough
it's like you can't have a private
moment
it's like every time you're an ass
unless off let's face it we're all asses
at times
it's got to be put into a compilation on
youtube you know
right right and and sometimes things
don't they're not what they seem or what
they appear and
too many marriages break up because uh
you know you just say that's it so we're
ready this
it sounds like you know
leave justin alone leave dustin alone i
don't know
the guy he has he's got to work on
himself he definitely needs to work on
himself that the thing about closing the
car door
was was very uh
aggressive and leaving her while he
crossed the street
for her to fend for herself that one
really that was rude
and uncalled for crowdy chops their face
too although that one's a little out of
context yeah that i
i'm not quite sure what was going on
there but
um you know okay
marriage is very good well we send our
love to the bieber family and we wish
them well
ultimately okay we've got a few
advice questions one specifically for
you mom
okay this is gonna be good
to ethan's mom i've reached the dating
age
okay and i'd like to know how to bag
a man
some dating techniques what is the way
into a man's heart
and be honest
oh wow um
well get yourself
gussied up gussied yes what does that
mean exactly
you know put on nice clothes
and and wear a nice perfume
and look put your effort in look yeah
the nails are nails important
um you know it depends on the type of
girl and the type of guy
nails i don't i don't have not gussied
your nails aren't good no
i don't but i i do have an appointment
but oh so we're going to gus
that's an expression that women used
when they got on the wagon trains to go
west
they all got gussied up for that big
long expedition
oh god anxious well that expression i
think that's the original
um i don't know god
i just think that you should be
affectionate
not too affectionate though like no no
no
um what god what do you do
i just think that you should just be
yourself
and um don't you know
i i don't know what to say how to keep a
man
how to keep a man happy she's speechless
a beautiful woman like
like mom says yeah just be yourself yeah
exactly easy for you well
i mean everyone's beautiful especially
when you're young
you know everyone's beautiful i just
think that
uh well you know put in some effort to
know
what he's about you know in inquire
talk to him don't spill your guts about
me me me you can
probe and find out about you know his
interests listen
yeah gussy listen gussy and listen
i think that's a good you know and and
and
if you really like the guy don't feel
uncomfortable about maybe touching his
hand
or you know don't touch me as justin
would say
yeah here's what i think oh listen to
ethan he's got some good advice i think
something really important to remember
when you're dating especially when
you're young
is that everybody's shy insecure so if
you like a guy
it's not bad to be forward right so if
you want to say hey you know
if you want to say it's even cute to be
like hey do you want to go on a date
do you want to hang out these are nice
cute things that are not going to turn
off a guy
you know so oh i thought they were
already on a date
well they're saying they're asking for
they're asking for
for tips how do we we've reached the
dating age how do we bag that man
i think you have to let a guy know you
like him because guys
definitely are shy yeah and their
insiders are much higher and secure than
you think yes
i think shared interests are important
so
like most guys like sports for example
so when you meet someone and they like
sports don't
say oh i hate sports i hate football
i've never watched anything
at least feign some interest in the
things that interest fake it
fake liking their stuff until you're
married
no if you hate sports fake that you like
sports
yeah they're two years when they're
friends once you get married
then say you're not allowed to hang out
with them anymore that's right right you
can't watch football on sundays anymore
i think just be i think confidence is
beautiful as always
be forward if you feel like you're in
this situation
like i think he likes me and i like him
and nobody's making a move it's okay to
just you know make that move
be confident lit like you said be
attentive
be flattering got people guys don't get
flattered enough they'll get complete
enough it's always
that the expectation is that the guy
because this is this is a woman asking
for advice so this is
it's always that the guy is expected to
compliment and court the woman
but a lot of times you know god if it's
very meaningful when men
receive compliments too so if you like a
guy and you're looking for ways to kind
of be affectionate with them
compliment him you know tell him that he
looks good today tell him he's funny
tell him you know
that he's handsome when you were dating
did anyone do that to you
do you remember that far back i wish
they did
ela i you know i
i think you're right though you just you
just have to let them
know that it's okay for them to approach
you exactly
that's the best advice so that's mom's
advice on bagging a man
that's it if you like it then you better
put a ring on it how do you feel about a
woman proposing to a man i propose to
your father so i think i guess she's in
favor of it
okay the next one is called a smelly
situation this one's tough
i currently work in an office that went
part-time remote during the pandemic
recently we switched to full time in the
office and it seems that throughout this
pandemic one of my co-workers have
forgotten
how to shower because they really stink
oh
we have drop hints to them using air
fresheners when they're around
and asking loudly what is that smell
what do you mean you give them air
fresheners just
here okay okay however
they just aren't getting the hint what
are some creative ways to tell someone
they smell
without hurting their feelings
i actually experienced something like
this oh my goodness
and i the gift was deodorant
in a lovely package with
bows and it was anonymous
yeah that's probably you're probably
gonna want to do something like that if
it's getting to the point
where their stink is actually disrupting
like i would say
if it's not that bad just you know
you're gonna have to endure it because
telling someone they stink
is not an easy task well it's got to be
a deodorant problem
so well i don't know yeah i mean it is
not then it's something really
if it is other stinks happening that
aren't bit related that you got big
issues
i think if you're not using an
antiperspirant you still perspire
if you know with other deodorants and
you can still have
a an odor what if everyone
went into the office wearing gas masks
that might do it why didn't anyone
everyone tell me we're wearing gas masks
yeah hint no just a gas mask it works
setting up caution tape around their
desk maybe
anonymous and and and you're gonna
deodorate you're gonna have to leave an
anonymous note or a deodorant it's kind
of passive aggressive
but maybe an anonymous letter that just
says hi
you know i don't want i don't want to be
rude
i i mean this is dude they'll give you
they'll you'll hurt their feelings well
just write like i'm very sorry to bring
this up but there is it there's i think
you need to shower more there's some
smell coming off you
peace and love god bless let's do
something about this smell 20 21 is the
year of not smelling
oh when i was in high school wait one of
the things that's really important
is is it a female or a male that smells
it's it's
unspecific but i'm assuming for some
reason that it's a man
it's got to be a man it's got to be
but you know there's no easy way to do
this so it's like first of all you have
to make that decision am i going to do
this
is it so bad that i have to do this
because it's going to hurt their
feelings
and then once you're once if it's so bad
that you literally can't endorse sitting
next to this person anymore
you're going to have to i wouldn't tell
them
i wouldn't tell them it will ruin your
relationship for hmm do you tell them do
you just don't be
you just own it and just be like listen
dude
i gotta break it to you man there's a
little bit of a stink coming off you
right now
i think if if it's a guy it needs to be
a guy that tells him yeah and
if if he's a good enough friend he could
say look at no
you know just basically what you're
saying and just be honest just be like
yeah i mean that that's one way
but i totally understand want to go in
the anonymous way too that could [ __ ]
with their head in another way because
they'll be looking over shoulder like
damn everybody in this office knows
those things which is probably true
yeah but you got it's almost like you
got you remember stinky feline
yes so how did it how did everyone
address that i don't think anyone ever
addressed it we just enjoyed the sting
well and that's european kind of none of
the other people
you should tell this you should tell the
story your your listeners don't we had
an exchange trip when i was in high
school
i hope she's not watching god bless
words
[Music]
she's in german germany and
uh a girl became my partner which means
she came and stayed with us for a month
and then i went and stayed with her mom
her family for a month in germany
so and when she came and visited us
there was just maybe she hid puberty not
like a skunk oh my god
it did she did not use deodorant well it
was a shark it was like b.o like i never
smelled it
it was a nice hot summer too boy well
and remember we drove
to santa barbara to the orchestra with
you guys yeah
oh that was smart oh my god all the way
to santa monica
you go into the door and and it hits you
this beautiful fragrance but
dinky flower she ruined the flower show
oh my god every time she walked back i
mean
we'd walk by booths and the orchids
would wilt she walked by
it was so bad so anyway it was well
known that
she had this odor and i think i don't
know what happened if she just
like hit because she was probably like
16 or something at the time we were all
about that age
and it's like she hit maybe she just hit
puberty and wasn't i don't cross that
bridge or putting on do it
but she was like a fully grown like i
mean you know yeah but you know
you said something about their family
that they didn't have a car
they lived in a farm you rode your
bicycle everywhere when everyone else
was
was you know it was more metropolitan
they took
yeah so i think that maybe i don't know
if she shaved her arms
she did i remember she would wear these
tank tops right
mm-hmm and they were like out breathing
yeah
yeah she she just didn't use deodorant
yeah the world's problem
she was the only one that could breathe
but didn't you end up gifting her a bar
deodorant you know i think i i think i
did my mom
slipped her barbecue after that car ride
i think i did i gave her some really
nice soap and
and slush or something yeah no there was
no sure do you think
um god i don't remember it was so long
ago but boy that stinky
throat was memorable oh stink of
fractals
stink a frauka that was yeah that was
unbelievable
not a very nice name we didn't call her
that by the way
but you know that's another if it if it
is a woman
that would be a very i'll watch this
that'd be so [ __ ] but you know
if it's a woman the poor pretty soap
you're gonna be you know you're a favor
this person's gotta know they stink
because the truth
is if you stink that bad you're walking
around everything all day long and
people being that person [ __ ] stings
and you don't want to be that person so
you either just
just own it and say listen as a
co-worker and a friend i respect you
you stink here i just being honest thank
you peace and love or you leave an
anonymous letter what else can you do
there was a family that got on an
airplane this was not too long ago
and they were asked to to leave because
they smelled so bad
wow a whole family of stinkers do you
remember gary
certainly it was it was new york so i'm
not going to say anything
more about yep yes oh those [ __ ] arts
stink the high heavens and we have they
they don't shower they wear these suits
and the
israel it's worse they were like big
caps and heavy jackets and even the
little two
can you imagine you can't buff a plane
for some thinking yeah they got
they literally were kicked off the plane
you can punch a
is that somewhere in the uh user it had
to be so offensive for them to be
asked to leave yeah but almost on the
little plane you could imagine probably
people in the back row were smelling
that uh there's one more thing we want
to do today you guys
are our resident boomers and you guys
probably don't use tick tock right
no i'm on the tick tock oh you're on
tick tock i am but
i used a different username oh please
not related to anything
having to do with me i don't want to see
your fees yeah i don't want to know
what's on your feed
me neither so anyway
um who are you
i've asked you guys to prepare what all
the kids are doing which is a tick tock
dance
oh and as i understand it you guys have
rehearsed we prepared
you know what we rehearsed we were
sweaty we we
heard so much and it was it's still
horrible i thought
well speak for yourself okay well we i
am speaking foreign what dance are we
doing
reviving can i say what's the dance it's
the twist
are you doing the twist bringing the
twist back it's we are
uh replicating step for step
the well the twist from
uh pulp fiction with uh
uh uma thurman and john travolta
aka vincent vega and uh
uh uh um
and uh i'm nowhere near there's the plot
of the
public yeah so there and what were they
doing at the time jackrabbits
and they have a dance contest all right
all right
that's where it's from ethan's got such
a headache
and if you haven't seen pulp fiction one
of the
best movies of all time okay so let's go
do the dance you guys can see it here
and also
on my tick tock super exciting this is
i'm expecting to get 50 million plus
views
huge i'm wearing my head i'm wearing my
pants from uh
like the 70s look that
well i said i want to dance i want to
win
i want that trophy another pulp fiction
reference
there you are on fire well that's just
before they dance all right let's go do
the dance
okay thank you for watching families
we'll see you thank you everyone
for on uh wednesday slash thursday off
the rails and friday we're working on
something a little special i know the
schedule's a little off because ela's
gone
we're working we're figuring it out
see you guys on that like button pound
i think it's well you can pound and
pound it slam it pound it smash it bop
it
all of those all right guys thank you
eats it
oh perfect but also that's not correct
usage but
you got 100 bucks all right good job
ciao
all right
[Music]
[Music]
you